these apes and Super Saiyans oh my these
are the ICONic power-ups Gohan has
gotten during his decades in the world
of Dragon Ball any Saiyan with a tail
who lays eyes on a full moon or
Powerball in Dragon Ball Z transforms
into a great ape an enormous cross
between a chimp and wolf that amplifies
the Saiyan's power 10-fold thanks to an
early bedtime however Gohan never
changes into a great ape until Piccolo
forces him to live in the wilderness
where he wakes up in the middle of a
full moon night stunned and panicked by
great ape Gohan's destructive and
uncontrolled power Piccolo zaps the moon
into nothingness and Yanks Gohan's tail
off removing the child's means of
transforming roughly a year later the
tail regrows and Gohan becomes a great
ape again thanks to a Powerball created
by Vegeta Vegeta cuts the new tail off
as well but golan's great ape form
reappears once more in the Tree of Might
before losing his tail for good and as
say monkey see monkey do
Gohan gains quite a few advantages in
the great ape before but it also has
plenty of drawbacks because he's never
taught how to control his Fury as a
monkey his behavior is completely
unpredictable making him as much a
danger to his friends as he is to his
foes Gohan's tale is also a huge
liability for the form as removing it
neutralizes the transformation applying
enough Force to it can temporarily
paralyze him or induce drowsiness this
ape may be great but he's still got some
pretty glaring weaknesses
in Vegeta's early mentions of the Super
Saiyan he makes it pretty clear that
such a powerful being isn't said to come
along very often however mere months
after Goku first reaches Super Saiyan
Future Trunks appears wielding the
transformation with ease after about
three years later Vegeta manages to
achieve the enhanced form as well it's
not long after that that a fourth Super
Saiyan debuts Gohan while training in
the hyperbolic Time Chamber Goku makes
it a point to have Gohan learn how to go
Super Saiyan of course Goku's savvy's
son realizes that he'll never become a
Super Saiyan as long as his dad keeps
treating him with kid gloves Gohan's
instincts proved to be right on the
money as Goku attacking with a lethal
Kamehameha is exactly what the half
saying needs to awaken his true power
while the scene is handled more plainly
in the manga the anime version is
extremely emotional featuring a powerful
flashback Montage of all the times Gohan
feels like he's failed in both versions
it's the first time a child is shown
becoming a Super say proving age isn't a
prerequisite for transforming it's not
Gohan's strongest transformation but
it's powerful regardless and the easiest
for him to use
in the seven years that pass after
Gohan's victory over cell the young man
more or less puts martial arts behind
him as a result he's defeated pretty
easily when Majin Buu hits the scene
luckily old Kai has an ability that can
bring every last drop of power in his
body out to the surface with that
ultimate Gohan also known as Mr Gohan is
born his debut is positively ferocious
as he humiliates Boo's latest stage
superboo with next to no effort Gohan's
Cockiness gets the better of him however
as his deliberate delay in vanquishing
boo allows the evil being to add Gotenks
and Piccolo's powers to his own
dramatically flipping the fight back in
Boo's favor regardless Gohan's ultimate
state is undeniably impressive it
features all the power from his two
Super Saiyan forms and then some better
still as long as Gohan keeps his
training up his ultimate State remains
his default form meaning he never has to
waste energy changing into it however
Gohan doesn't continue training
regularly after booze defeated and he
has to go to Piccolo for help
transforming again I want to see some
press saying for many years ultimate
Gohan appeared to be the strongest State
Gohan would ever reach however the
return of the Red Ribbon Army in Dragon
Ball super superhero proves that
assumption wrong in a big way while
fighting the monolithic Cell Max Piccolo
comes up with a plan he tells Gohan to
charge an energy attack of his choice
while the namekian distracts their
opponent unfortunately celmax is still
quite a handful even when Piccolo
combines his orange state with his giant
form as a result Cell Max actually
subdues Gohan's Mentor lifting him up
while roaring in Triumph that turns out
to be the wrong move as Gohan's Fury at
seeing Piccolo badly hurt summons a
brand new power he didn't even know he
had Gohan Beast is the most visually
unique of all of Gohan's Transformations
unlike his Super Saiyan forms which
turns his hair gold and eyes green Gohan
Beast gains gray hair and bright red
eyes his Aura is a stunning mixture of
white pink and blue with electricity
crackling around him the special beam
Cannon he uses on Cell Max is an equally
jaw-dropping blend of red and blue
energy Beast is Gohan's most powerful
form to date and the first he undergoes
in which he's fully in control of
himself from the start though it does
somewhat affect his personality Gohan
it's due or die time so draw it all of
your strengths Goku's plan to have his
son win the Cell Games it's a major snag
when Gohan reveals that fighting just
doesn't agree with him as a result Gohan
doesn't know how to act when cell
attacks him and torches his friends with
the cell Juniors unexpected guidance
comes from Android 16 but just as the
robot finishes imparting his words of
wisdom cell crushes him a switch seems
to go off inside Gohan energy erupts
from his being changing him into a state
that previously even eluded his father
Super Saiyan 2 a whirlwind of events
follows culminating in Gohan destroying
cell with a massive Kamehameha Super
Saiyan 2 Gohan isn't as strong as Gohan
Beast or ultimate Gohan nor is it as
second nature to him as his base Super
Saiyan 4 so why does the top of the list
because of the significance of its debut
of course this is the first time Gohan
has ever surpassed Goku in both power
and skill setting the stage for him to
assume Goku's place as Earth's main
Defender when his dad decides to stay in
other worlds Super Saiyan 2 Gohan's
introduction will forever be viewed as a
badass passing of the torch and coming
of age moment plus the long upright gold
hair gold Aura and sparkling blue
electricity look incredibly cool its
only real downside is that like almost
all of Gohan's Transformations it brings
out a bloodthirst on first usage leading
him to make some unfortunate mistakes
foreign